wait is it uk yeah yeah it's only you
only uk no it's only
one isn't good one there's one season in
america i think it came out 2019.
i don't care about american reality
shows i don't know
uk reality shows are where it's at
they're so good but what it's called uh
love island
love island uk and over there it's a big
deal
it's important they're all really famous
over there and so we
so just so our listeners know we're in
boise
and jay we you know the we do airbnbs
and jay's like oh have you seen love
island and everyone's like no
and he put it on we fell in love with it
love island season six
shout out to season six is that the one
we were watching yeah yeah
yeah it was a moment that we literally
was so invested that we
when a guy got picked we all high-fived
each other
really invested with the guys yeah so
then we were all hyped on it then we
come back home
and then we all told everyone has girls
we told our girls so you start watching
the girls
but we watched probably five or six
episodes with the boys we stopped in
boise
so i told my girl back she's like oh i'd
love to watch that because we got done
with uh
made at first sight season five [ __ ]
terrible done
done with that show done with that show
oh really i only like the new seasons
the old ones suck
anyway so i was like go check out this
love violin i explained it to her she's
like oh cool
so i started on the episode we were on
and boys she's like whoa
no like we got to go back to season one
or episode one i went oh
i'm not i'm out
we're gonna start season five i haven't
seen season five we're gonna start there
i'm not going back and doing this yeah
it's just like
it's easy to explain dude there's
nothing worse than re-runs of reality
show
yeah it was so weak yeah but season five
lily like a titty tyson fury's little
brother's on there who is a
smoke show is it really type of furious
little brother half bro professional
boss
oh shoot tommy fury is dimed pieced up
okay because i'll be furious you know
what's awkward with your girl because
the way the show works if you guys
haven't seen it
it's like four or five girls four or
five guys and they pick each other
so when you're watching with your girl
they'll be like well which one would you
pick
that's him bro he's fine so can i can i
testify real quick
watched it with my girlfriend she asked
questions she she goes oh so that's what
you're into oh my god
oh my cause the twins is on episode 6
and she's twins
bodied up best bodies i've seen in 2000
they are fantastic fantastic they and
then they walk around with their cheeks
out
so it kind of gets the whole show the
whole show so it gets uncomfortable
because your girls see you staring at
those cheeks
so she goes just happy to be on the
screen yeah she was like they saw oh my
god would you
would you want me to walk around like
that i'm like no you don't have those
bodies
you don't you have a flat
their faces are a little what but their
bodies are ridiculous and they dress
really cool
i apologize but dude season five because
we like these girls yeah we
mix it up season five uh tommy fury and
then this professional dancer come in
and he's a male dancer but they're like
they're the male dime pieces
equivalent to the twins like it shakes
the whole thing everyone wants them it's
always dude tommy fury's laying it down
it's great
are they hooking up are they hooking up
on that one yes i'm only on episode
three
no dude what's going on oh there's a
fine ass surfer this blonde server with
kids
and she's and she's and she's talking to
this guy and they're hitting off
and she was like can you because they
were doing like uh
never have i ever and they'd have to
take a drink yeah some dude was like
never have i ever hooked up in a public
place
and she's going to start drinking i was
like oh and she fine and freaky
and she was like i hooked up with this
guy in a club i was like oh hell yeah
and then and the guy was they went off
on their own because they like
locked up and he was like oh man like
we're all in the same room like it's
kind of
could you hook up with someone here
she's like absolutely not i was like
[ __ ] oh everybody i was like
i think she has to say that by the way
but there's a black a light skinned
black girl on there who's only 21
dumb as rocks but great to look at
that's why i like really that's why i
like that and they paired up with a
mechanical yeah i think he's a
aviation engineer but he's really smart
dime piece white dude
and they're talking and he's like you're
young aren't you she's like how do you
think i'm he's like
i don't know 20. she's all 21. he's like
that's cool
makes it and then they go to the
personal interview and he's like she's
nice
because he's like stupid smart yeah so
stupid
oh are they paired up yeah oh she's
funny she looks like she's fine season
five
season five championship check this out
let's see this cast like season five but
it's i think it's better than season six
here's the thing bro
you it's a lot of time in because it's
50 episodes
wait that's 50 it's 50 episodes in one
season in one season
yeah because the way love island works
over in the uk is they air an
episode every single day until it's done
you didn't know that
so every single day you can tune in and
you can watch almost live what's
happening day by day
bro it's 50 years
one show a night like you're winding
down before bed and you watch
a 45 minute episode every single night
that's not season five chin
i talked in season five season five uk
bro let's see
there it is the black guy's a butter
face
[Laughter]
i'm glad you had the black guys there's
the thick one on the right
i'm pretty sure she has a fake ass which
one is the 21 year old the one in the
middle come on bro oh come on
she's right there right here she's
standing up too
i love her what's her name i don't know
i never know any characters names from
any show i watch
that's australia yeah but it's 50
episodes oh there they are she
scroll into that chin
so the blonde surfers the curly in the
back she doesn't look great there she is
the guy next to her is the butterface
black guy bodied up there on the bottom
also a butterface bodied up these guys
got that black dude yeah then there's
kim kardashian the far left that's the
girl
who with the fake ass and it ain't bad
to look at it's not okay
okay yeah but it's weird it's weird with
no no oh that guy no he's actually
pretty cool
dress is the best too uh what's up with
his eyebrows though yeah i was
curious and he's uh hairless oh he's
inside shaves
and so that surfer girl they're
[Music]
me mom me mom you what are you really
those twins those twins are twins
twins yo uh literally they they stole
the episode they they stole this uh
episode six i don't want to spoil it for
you
but who did the twins yes so this new
black guy
handsome by the way tall six three big
do you know the girl that we hate
well yes yes which one celine uh
selena whatever her name is whatever so
she was dissing our boy nast the whole
show you know
everybody says he's cute no one's like
the first friend
he's like the friend he should be on
that show he shouldn't he shouldn't have
been
a poor guy he's really looking for love
yeah nobody loves him well he's trying
hard dude
he is bro this show is
big over in uk it's huge like they
become big celebrities
yeah that's [ __ ] no we went on their
instagrams and
nothing but like millions of followers
only one had 25 000 and that was ollie
because you quit episode three
yeah i didn't like it the show is
fantastic shout out to love we watched
that in boise which were hooked on we
watched uh
the big mouth the new season season four
big mountains are hilarious
that show's funny they got the anxiety
mosquitoes i need i need to go back to
the yeah you put us on that
dude yeah shout out to nick it's
fantastic yeah it's so well done
yeah yeah the new episode it's the the
black girl and she acts real nerdy white
yeah and she gets with a like a ghetto
black dude he's talking about how he
changes his accent like his
blackness and what crowd he's hanging
out with it's so funny i think he's uh
jack knight that does that character
shout out to jack he's killing it that's
so great you want to talk about how dope
this show was in boise oh boise was oh
liddy like a [ __ ] tim say it again
insane cause we
pulled up and i was like oh i was
clowning oh clown
and steve got there before us and jay
was like oh this place is dope you're
gonna love it
yep we pull up like this is some
[ __ ]
describe yeah describe what we pulled up
to like some kind of like guy looks like
a haunted house warehouse you know when
you're walking
housing [ __ ] where are you like
inside that [ __ ] was
dope the green room was made for like
big sean's crowd
like it was a lot of dudes why are you
saying like that though why did you he
was there
well yeah but i heard dude it was big
sean i forget who else in logic
big sean logic i mean yeah i mean
whatever
this top five oh yeah i love life i
heard only like 16 people showed up to
this [ __ ]
i bet that [ __ ] was just lit it wasn't
lit but anyway so
that club that that theater is fantastic
fantastic and it was half capacity
half competition and it was lit i didn't
post
the video of the crowd because i don't
want the hate yeah that thing was lit
it was it was insane but like the best
crowd we've had best crowd dude
this whole time yeah youtube's special
on that [ __ ]
you said that hey here's the thing
listen i want to go back in the summer
because it was freezing and it was half
capacity you go back in the summer
and i can ride bikes and [ __ ] yeah do
more youtube fishing
it was so cold good food though where's
the place we went you recommended it you
found it no
the first night oh the first cook my own
steak like the [ __ ] scene
that [ __ ] was popping what was that
hello hold on the girl dm me she took
care of our tab and we took care of her
so it was the saint lawrence gridiron
remember that
she's a she didn't do that
by the way he wanted to go to red robin
so bad hey it was next-door red robin
which was lit
whiskey barbecue burger and the steak
fries dude yeah with their seasoning
salt i haven't been there before i know
i've been there you know when
i haven't i didn't eat all day so i was
just starving i started thinking about
the red robin menu history
and that place was like looked whatever
that place was good though bro we
literally eat the exact same yeah
literally y'all's like how long we're
going to pretend
what you getting dog you getting the
biscuits and gravy i was thinking about
it
oh i didn't get back on my diet duffy i
know we're doing good well i am
at least people been saying it
as far as like chains go red robin don't
miss
you said red robin red robin red robin's
fan the bonsai burger oh that's the
whiskey river
yeah that's huge brenner you eat that oh
yeah
yeah i haven't in years but when i was a
kid we would get our [ __ ] allowance
we'd
ride our bikes there on a friday night
and then my one boy's
neighbor was our waitress and she was
fine we just like flirt with her and we
didn't have a
chance she was a senior we're in eighth
grade you had a chance
i don't think so hey look
so so tell them what display jay's uh
texting me the
name of the spot right now but tell them
why you ordered the steak and you
complained they came on i didn't
complain to them and complain to you
guys because you get like
what are you known for she goes we're
known for our rock steak oh yeah
it's like the they heat it's a fillet
and it comes on a real
700 degrees like charcoal plate yeah
that was one of those like trendier
like steak houses i guess because that's
really trendy lately i would
watch a bunch of instagram videos of
people like heating up these like hot
plates and just like cooking their own
meat
bro i don't go to a restaurant
i don't want to do you i was so pissed
you got rare too i got rare that [ __ ]
came out wrong
it came out yeah raw and i was like what
the [ __ ] is this and she's like oh you
just got to rotate it
[Laughter]
it's the best because what they do is if
you order
rare then they're going to go a step
down yeah of course cause they want you
to cook it a little bit yeah and i'm
like
see they never did that so they was i
don't want to cook my own food yeah
she was like bro i out of state i
already did oh how about the how about
the
the table armors next to us yeah they're
chilling having a good time
uh sure i'm not making a black widow
falls on his shoulder
and he's uh yeah they all get up and
[ __ ] freak out yeah black widow black
widow
and then i go let me see the let me see
it sure enough big ass black
big ass black widow would you a freaked
out
uh yeah probably they ain't coughing
their meal they didn't put that black
widow in there
they probably did they count their meal
their name is barbacoa
barbecue it was fantastic yeah those
wings were great too
beds were good yeah we had their wings i
had a shirley temple that was great
yeah the wings were really good the
wings were the ribs were good i'm
talking about shirley temple
i know i always feel so good although
those ribs were really good
the ribs were good yeah all the dessert
i had decaf coffee and then they had
fried ice cream popsicle sticks
on a tree and you put honey it was like
like a tree
they had a decorator yeah it was so
beautiful dude boise is
fantastic it was it was pretty dope our
airbnb was dope
yeah we couldn't wait to get back in the
house because the
the floor was heated yeah and we could
get all snugly on the couch
we was all snuggled up and then uh the
girl from season six we started clowning
she had
her legs stevie said something like
earlier in the day he's like doug her
legs are thick and
everyone's like whatever stevie and then
we got back after the show
we were watching i was like dog her legs
are crazy
i was like yo run that back it was a row
session for 10 minutes
yeah 10 minutes on her i said she got
those steve austin legs
her legs are so big she got diabetic
legs
we was just going in on this support use
some of her legs dog
yeah you guys need to meet in the middle
doug yeah me the middle i mean that
jersey's fire where'd you get that oh
thank you nba.com
really yeah the uh the the camera yeah
the kid but they don't rock those do
they yeah they do oh damn
yeah that's another big one authentic
yeah mitchell ns
hardwood classic oh wow yeah damn that's
a legit one yeah thank you
i love some bootleg like camo edition
yeah i know i was yeah i was like i hope
he doesn't do anything bootleg
why would i do that i don't know i don't
like how this just went like i buy
bootleg stuff for one by the way good
thing
looking out for um the weekend i
appreciate that i want to talk to you
about snoring again i don't want to be
bro this guy's snoring this guy is so
bad that i saw we go to bed we're tired
right
they had bunk beds we had bunk beds
right so not bum bass
we had we had two beds in the same room
stevie was in a bunk bed and she was
like i'm not sleeping on a bunk bed and
then took his mattress and went down
he's so gangster by the way that was so
good he had it decorated nice he had it
all set up
you can tell stevie was in prison
because everything's always like real
nice
nice is he makes his bed in the morning
like he's on call i think i wake up and
he's just out front
that's all right
did you keep making coffee sir i'm like
don't call me
santa's license plate name 36-47 yeah
but this so this guy right it's like 11
o'clock at night still early in the day
in boys it's 10 it's 10 and uh cali
he's on his phone i'm like bro good
night he was like he's saying good night
to your ass he's mean on the road
right so he's mean on the road he turns
off his phone
and he go all i hear is i'm not he's a
cool little snore right
then he snores awkward and loud he goes
that is a lot i swear to god
bro like a lot more [ __ ] what a god
it can't be worse than jay no it's worse
than jake i'm telling you i went in the
other room i went in the middle
for years let me sleep in the same room
because jay snores so loud is it like a
sleep apnea type of snore that's what's
going on
how it is you know what it is and i i
gotta be honest with you
and jay yeah because you guys are
overweight
i just want to be very clear that's why
you snore
if you if everyone got a little a little
more healthy
no i said it i said it i can't believe
you just did that i have an issue myself
with my weight
but you guys have a snoring problem
because you're out of shape no
listen you died three times in your
sleep i counted kiss my ass yo listen
whatever
hey let me tell you something whenever
my nose is stuffed up
that's when i snore oh my god
you don't got no ass you're the same
like me like
you it was used in afrin you know when
you use that for to clear your name
it's fantastic for the first day or two
but then uh after three days it has a
reverse effect where it leaves your nose
more clogged yeah this full thought is
using saline solution because
my nose was stuffed because uh allergies
and [ __ ] out there and i go hey dog can
you uh
let me use that spray cause he bought it
i go this is afrin this that real [ __ ]
he goes
no it's saline solution i've been using
it for days yeah i was using it for like
a week
wow and my nose was so stubborn and it
was like even worse
like it was so stuffed up that it was
making me lightheaded yesterday was the
first day i didn't use any of it and
then finally this morning i woke up my
nose is clear
i had to power through on on saturday
for the show i don't know why you didn't
use it for the show
i will not go out easily in the show
because i didn't want to i was like i
was already freaking i freaked out over
[ __ ] anything drug related so i
i didn't want to take any more i was
like i don't know yeah cause i heard you
can get addicted to that [ __ ]
the buddy was super addicted to it this
is like
what it's just like stuffing up your
nose and cleaning yourself
but then but then you come dependent on
it had a buddy in high school was
dependent on
anthony turner and he would use it every
day like
he'd go through [ __ ] bottles every
week like four or five bottles a week
because you get addicted to it because
eventually you can't breathe without it
yeah and it restricts it restricts your
breathing
so bad you're like so depressed bad bad
and that's the two of them
then it barely like you you like when
you first use it you have 100 breathing
capacity
then it goes to like 80 the next thing
you know it's like 30 degrees
yeah you can't breathe at all without it
that's why i didn't take it that night
no but this is the first night it i
don't know what i'm saying the first
night
you didn't take it no yeah his nose and
stuff because because i had bought it
that night and then i gave it
for him to use cause i said let me get
ahead of that and that's when he uh him
and jay gave me the information that
that [ __ ] [ __ ] your if you keep using
it and i've been using it for like a
week
because i went to arizona and arizona
[ __ ] up my allergies bad
well so kiss my ass all right well and
kiss my ass for calling me fat
i like you guys i said one of the
reasons you got
is because you're overweight yeah it's a
sure sign of being overweight they say
well yeah
because i don't i don't know what you
did that is what it is dude
yeah because saturday night is the
[ __ ] synonym for is it synonym
sure just go with it for uh [ __ ]
overweight
or is it what is it what is the word
yeah you got it
you if you lost weight you went snores
but yeah 100
because i get you with the sinus thing
that was friday night what is your
excuse on saturday night
i didn't use it yeah but you'll snore
you stuffed up cause i'm stuffed up
oh bro yep kiss my hand
i'm just saying it's bad i don't want to
move with him anymore that's all i'm
just tough
it stays tough i can't do it i'm such a
light sleeper you heard me snore yeah it
wasn't bad i was recording him because i
was coming but he went
[ __ ] out on instagram but it was a nice
snore really
it was like a baby bro
you and jay got one more you caught him
a baby 14 more times to call me a baby
hey so so stevia was like no fans in
here trust me let's go to this
restaurant we were looking for a food
and stevie's like i'm already at the
restaurant me to say i go where's that
he goes
next door to the venue i don't want to
do that dude drunk fans give me a
nightmare he goes
dude there's no fans in there sure
enough we walk in
yeah it was a big table yeah yep because
everyone's the same [ __ ] they're done
with the
thing they want to find food they
they're doing the same thing yeah
and it's not a big area where like
there's not uh everything closes there's
not much to do there there's not much to
do so everybody's probably gonna go
to that place there's a trump rally when
we're there yeah it was like
they had all the security at the venue
because there's these anti-mass people
and whatever venues going on they
disrupt they come in and just start
marching
against anti-mask so they were going to
march my venue but
it didn't make sense yeah because you
was yeah we was in there like you know
masked off at the table
yeah at the time but no no that wasn't a
trump rally she said those were
anti-masculine that's what i'm saying
but no we saw the trump there's a trump
rally going on the flag during the day
there's a trump rally
yeah that was one of them really oh i
think she was saying that wasn't not the
capital at the capitol but here's the
thing
trump won i don't so what are their
protests i don't know
i don't know i don't know but they were
all out i mean there was a couple of one
it wasn't very video it wasn't it wasn't
it was like 14. it's a sad round
there were 12 of them on a facebook
group i don't know i don't know what
they're
protesting there was no microphone i
know there was a microphone just [ __ ]
shouting what did he say oh that's carl
carl carl carl's going to speak louder
this is first time it was so awkward i
don't know what they're protesting
it's like it's over who knew who knew
although me and jay started arguing
because and i was like dude they need to
stop this he's like no
there's a chance trump could still win
18
chance like yeah [ __ ] dude then when he
explained it i was like that you sure
that's eighteen percent
[ __ ] sound like six he's full of [ __ ] oh
gosh
boys it was so fun i had a blast dude
i'd go back have you been there before
never
see it what about you never but when
they when they first asked me to do it i
was like man i don't know boise that's a
weird market
i love the the the state like idaho's
[ __ ] dope but i love potatoes as far
as like
comedy i don't know man then i hit up
bert because he tours a lot of hit up
bird i hit up josh wolfe and all
joe coy who's done uh that uh boise
and all three are like dude one of the
best it was one of the best yeah
seriously
seriously they were not lying he walked
out there
and it was no introduction to anything
it's just like you know the most nervous
i've been for a show in a long time
because
theater they've never done comedy there
security the manager was
saying the stuff that would scare you in
the back she's like oh yeah we never had
comedy here like
yeah these are things we should look for
i was like ah [ __ ]
they're playing country before we went
off yeah we have to turn that up
yo bro shout out to you for being like
so cool like she was like we
i guess stevie and jay you know showed
up to the venue early and they was like
yo can we just turn it off and put some
hip hop on
she was like hip-hop oh you got to be
joking i'll cry don't love that
then brendan over here like overlook
he's like listen no can you just put on
some hip-hop she's like alright cool
as soon as he she put on that hip-hop
yeah it was a different thing
it they let their hair down bro i got
into a dance battle with a dude
he was killing me really he was killing
me the white guy yeah white guy he shot
don't shoot yourself yeah yeah white
white like he's a dance instructor
yeah but i didn't know you could dance
is what i'm saying
no one got it no one got on film no
because the security guard
he was no he had his drink in his hand
he went all the way were you right there
i was not oh he went all the way low he
did his legs like this it came
up
no no i literally i think it was steve
you're justin he killed me by the way
the security guard the security guard
right there by the justin and stevie not
get that on yeah what the hell no but
this we didn't you got me on film
beating the [ __ ] out of you and ping
pong oh yeah you didn't beat this [ __ ]
out of you
you had to keep you up like ten to two i
had to get on stage i was getting warmed
up i had to get on stage
but by the way i had to get on stage and
a lot of things was going through my
mind because you know it's a big fight
this weekend earl spence and danny
garcia big fight
didn't we bet on it yeah we bet on it we
bet on it yeah i said it's gonna be a
good fight
yeah spencer dominated all rounds well
wasn't that competitive
did you watch the fight yes did you like
it highlight
i watch highlights
thank you for being honest
listen this guy is so good
i gotta choose because when i hit the
ground uh sunday i gotta catch up on all
the [ __ ] i miss
so i barely saw any of the ufc so i
watched the ufc from top to bottom
oh i actually have to watch that because
i get a [ __ ] talk about it right
yes i watch the ufc then boxing unless
it's like
real controversial oh you just see the
highlights that's fair and it was not
controversial
all right well yeah you see spence and
uh bud crawford talking [ __ ]
yeah but he was like but it wasn't
they're friends so it's top like i've
been at
i've been at venues with them like when
i did the the what i do
no yeah when i did brooklyn and also i
think that when we did vegas for the
connor floyd stuff they were all back
there and they're buddies
yeah so they're like trying to talk [ __ ]
because everyone wants to see them fight
and it's so bad
yeah it'd be like me talking [ __ ] like
it's like they're friends
yeah so it's like you know he's like
well look at the guys i beat i knocked
him down
and he said i knocked him down too he's
like so that's not even a valid pair
i it's like dog nobody wants to see you
because my friends you guys are home
everybody want to see that fight though
but boxing you're not going to get it
you're going to get pacquiao versus
uh spence next and bud's going to fight
who god knows
because because oh yeah he beat his last
fight keith
you get the [ __ ] out of him but i'm
saying yeah tears crawford messed up
because he did that
he but he didn't sign with top rank
right he would
renegotiate his contract with like five
years but now bob aaron was like yo
well yeah
so this is my thing i'm below the belt i
think box is a little bit of trouble
because now
nobody's nobody nobody besides you and
me and some boxing heads are talking
about
spence and bud or spence and danny
garcia everybody in the mom talking
about logan paul and floyd mayweather
damn and this is why we're talking about
tyson versus so is that
is that real yeah that's real yeah i'm
upset i talked to logan paul this
morning yeah
i'm upset with floyd though damn
he's the goat in my eyes and some can
disagree no that's fine
okay all right no 100 there's a definite
argument it's an argument you know he
chose his opponents you know he
cherry-picked whatever but
listen 50 tried 50th failed right yes so
if you're considered one of the goats
yes why would you even entertain now i
no it's exhibition money i know it's
money i know and he does anything for
money but if you you can't argue this
if a if there's an exhibition put a head
gear on that's all i'm saying but this
is a real
boxing match and you consider one of the
goats you wouldn't see
jordan play i don't know lamelo ball
before you see what i'm saying that's
why i'm saying box in a little bit of
trouble because
logan paul's one and one wait no he's
only one he's over one
one he has one loss one draw he didn't
want to fight yet oh was that a draw
so he's owen one technically yeah he's
only been boxing for two years
yes isn't he a bigger guy yeah yeah way
bigger so why is he
that's why it's a little bit like but
even with that like
even though he's bigger it's floyd
mayweather dude
yeah it's a tie i don't know i don't
know you see how much paper
24.99 i know it's so cheap and and but
here's the thing if you get it early
it's 24.99 if you wait till the night of
the fight i think it's 69.99
a lot of people are going to buy it it's
money is floyd mayweather coming back to
the ring
if i'm floyd it's it's money in the bank
it's like hold up you want me to fight
the student get 100 mil
yeah i'll fight him it's 400 mil
hopefully i make 100 mil floyd really
doesn't do anything
for less than 100 mil yeah that's great
yeah he's smart dude
but but but if you're floyd why wouldn't
you do it well but
he's gonna do connor after that but
we're gonna fight connor again
he talked about it he goes because they
they asked him about the connor fight i
was
watching this interview and he goes i
could took him out in the first round
because if i
really wanted to apply the pressure i
would took him around the first round he
goes but people paid money i want to
give him a show you guys also
if i start him in the first two rounds
there's no rematch yeah is that smart
dude that's true meaning like
if you just went in and starched them
there's no rematch like
no one wants to see it got it now it's
like connor did pretty well first six
rounds let's be honest dude pretty well
landed up okay and then kind of gassed
out so it's like oh if connor
fixes that yeah now this is me coming
from an mma side it's like
all right if connor fixes that doesn't
gas out we got ourselves a fight
but that's what we're riding on you're
gonna get my money for that well
floyd like he that's how he fights in
spawn he'll walk you down
and he's lit dog house rounds he is no
minutes there's no time so but that's a
that's where everyone makes a
misconception about floyd oh he's such a
defensive fighter yes the
greatest defensive fight of all time go
back to floyd it's early
pretty much a [ __ ] assassin monster
he could go toe to toe with anybody 100
yeah but but now he's older and wiser
but it's an argument
from connor versus floyd when they first
started because
you can jump in it after this i make
this point when conor
was big in the ufc he was the best
striker in ufc correct hands it still is
okay still is
floyd best defensive fighter but it was
the illusion if conor hit him
man connor he's different floyd never
seen his style so was that and that's
the name
that's why i got a job with showtime
yeah okay exactly no pardon the pain i'm
not narrative what what does
youtube jay paul logan paul has to offer
besides the views i give because logan
paul is so much bigger than conor floyd
i've seen floyd sports i know
i know dude this is the narrative right
okay and it's kind of weird to go on it
because
jake paul did an interview chamber time
on below the belt
where he goes they go how can you beat
connor he goes well i'm way bigger
because i'm way bigger i'm stronger and
i'm a bigger guy
it's like bubba dude bro
i told chan i said dude there's how many
bouncers in the world that all way
bigger than floyd are way bigger than
connor
and they would beat the [ __ ] [ __ ] out
of those guys back to back yeah easily
in a bar fight
so why why do this fight and why not
just do the con the money the money
connor and uh because that kind of the
rematch that connor's never going
anywhere he'll do both
he'll go go fight logan paul i don't
know how many rounds it is six oh
probably
probably six days for him that's easy
money doug but now here's the
but but here's here's the i'm just
saying here's why they're gonna get my
money
okay what if logan paul landed a big
punch we said that about connor connor
landed a big punch but
he probably did that purposely you
showed me the video well he didn't get
hit with that uppercut i guarantee i
wait
he did not get hit but you understand
floyd was walking him down floyd doesn't
fight like that
he's gonna box floyd can fight like that
though yeah he can't he showed everyone
that he's gonna let logan paul like get
him get the ropes and he'll be chucking
and driving that's gonna wear him down
listen i get what you're saying but do
you really in your honest opinion do you
really think he's gonna land on floyd
mayweather something silent
look at it so he got a draw here uh are
you lost ksi
i know oh my god
by the way he is he's kept talking he's
way taller than floyd aguirre how tall
is he
like six two six two years ago two
hundred some pounds two
two fifteen oh my god but look at look
no defense
you don't think floyd is going man
floyd's going to walk him down
if floyd wants to he won't float him
flow to entertain it for
three four rounds you're right what
happened
again what happens if in some thing
floyd's not respecting him let's just
say floyd's like th this [ __ ]
youtuber have a thousand fights this is
money
okay gets clocked but that's not floyd
mentality i'm just saying what happens
if he did what if logan paul is logan
paul banking on that oh yeah
that's all he's banking on that's all he
really wants to beat his ass
well he thinks because he's they're
smaller he can go in there if he lands
when it's over
which is insane to think well i'll help
you get ready logan
help him get ready help them get ready i
mean you then you just
you're floyd's boy though right yeah
well i'm saying what would happen to
boxing if
if logan paul were to land and wobble
him i mean
what would happen yeah then i then you
get the floodgates open of all these
youtubers
mike perry's so funny my dm's mike
perry's like dog how long
like there goes how long are we going to
pretend that jake and logan paul can
fight
and i damn tobacco yeah i said dude i
get it but then boys making money can't
be mad at that can't be me because i'm
not mad i'm gonna teach my he has a son
coming he goes
i'm gonna teach my son to be a youtube
boxer how much money they're making [ __ ]
you
yeah i'm one of them well are the gates
already flooding ever since uh
his brother jake paul knocked out nate
robinson well like shannon sharp goes uh
they go are you excited for the logo
floyd mayweather fight and he goes yes
because we're going to get him back he
goes nate robinson represented all of us
as a professional athlete yeah yeah
right you start yeah
what if floyd does lose then it's more
it's better for boxing
no it's an exhibition it doesn't count
it's not going to go on his record
and it does not though it does all of it
counts it does even though it's just
that he's got a point well you're the
only reason around the only
hold on the only reason the exhibition
is because you couldn't get that
sanctioned as a real
fight no but we know it's a fight yeah
it's not like tyson uh
you can get you can get a section he had
two professional boxing matches
but against other guys that are o and o
against floyd who's
50 and oh yeah and has a thousand fights
no commissions in sanctions okay
they'd have to go like the dr or maybe
russia or something i cannot japan
and i'm sure you can't throw your
curveball lomachenko second fight
florida guy
second fight two-time olympic gold
medalist i know but he's the
commissioner knows that though so
they're gonna grant that access
you know what i'm saying i'm just saying
like the only reason my fight
uh got sanctioned by uh
the nevada athletic commission when i
thought roy okay i only had four fights
doug
he had over 30 and a former world
champion i had four fights
against just whoever they should have
never made that no that would never get
sanctioned but they got sanctioned
because it was an ultimate fighter
and the ufc has the nevada state
athletic commission in their pocket
yeah because it was on multiple fighters
a tournament he got sanctioned but
let's say i signed with the ufc at 4-0
and they tried giving me uh roy nelson
it probably wouldn't get sanctioned
i should have never been fighting that
man but you but you did and you won
i did not win that's when i lost the
ultimate fighter
oh cause oh cause it was a mismatch yeah
oh got you so the same thing with this
but did people watch it did people buy
into it my favorite yeah the champion
the most watched of all time yeah so you
know
same thing with this situation right i
get what you're saying it's a mismatch
and floyd it's an event it's not even a
boxing match it's called the event
because he
he said tank tank davis with who we all
love is going to fight in the co-main
event
but he wants to fight his brother so i'm
like okay now this hey he wants to fight
jake's brother
yes we're going down a weird bro
now you understand why i'm coming i
don't know what dude i was speechless on
below the belt smart because i had to
break stuff down and
it's just like i don't know how to go
about it doesn't make any sense it's
just
i don't know if it's good for boxing
like i love logan
logan's my boy i hope he makes a [ __ ]
hundred million dollars but just like
i don't i don't know i don't know where
you go yeah i don't know where the sport
goes they wouldn't do this in ufc at all
never thank you so i'm saying so boxing
because you know what we're talking
about the ufc
tony ferguson versus uh charlie oh
charles oliveira which is
an insane fight insane fight number six
versus number three like
that's a fight yeah but now yeah why is
boxing doing this well but but
you you discredit earl spence and danny
garcia very too skillful by
boxing uh two of the best and and their
views i think will
get the numbers uh can't be great what
do you mean
i bet you it's less than four hundred
thousand it was pa
it was pay-per-view right yeah okay i
think the numbers didn't come out yet
though
no it's just saying i think yeah it's
too soon but but but look at the tyson
and roy jones that was like over a
million pay-per-view box 1.6
yes but now is that roy and tyson or is
that jake paul
who's the the most famous guy in the
card
and starched homeboy yeah they made that
made
you know what i'm saying it's like but
but i'm saying now it's a mockery now
you have now you got mayweather and lo
oh oh
click on how much spence and danny
garcia made
right there i think it made over like
another purse buy it yeah i know i know
earl got
over a million right
yeah over 1 million plus revenue share
of pay-per-view
yeah so you know he's making [ __ ] man
two three million uh a fight off that
fight yeah but i'm saying it and that's
low for earl but i'm saying this
now i watch sports and i watch
undisputed i watched all that this
morning hey no one no one mentioned like
a very few stickers yeah it was a tiny
segment
and then do you know what majority of
the segment was floyd versus
what i'm saying yeah it's like no one
cares about like that
but imagine you growing up you know who
else is fighting who anthony joshua uh
oh and po apollo the heavy heavyweights
that's a great noise
it's next saturday oh this saturday this
saturday and you know it's crazy
yeah yeah josh was us got kovale uh
what's his name uh kalischko ready for
the guy he's fighting and my
the guy who used to uh train me my old
boxing coach is training the heavyweight
public who loves
no [ __ ] punk now he's not who is he
looking he's he's old though he's old
he's also like a smaller heavyweight
yeah but he's he's a huge dog
though joshua's a bad man with jammer
yeah but this guy's old as hell
cool he's cool yeah that's him right
here oh this would be a good fight yeah
he's that old face
no the according to vegas odds like but
i want to watch it minus 4 000. yeah but
this is a huge
you guys don't want to snuggle up and
watch it i'm going to watch it yeah i'm
going to watch it as well shout out to
my coach
trying to hang out i'm saying youtube is
one of my favorite fighters you think so
i love joshua
i don't know i like joshua tyson fury no
tyson is my favorite boxer oh okay okay
i'm about to say tyson
you know all of them easy
but i'm saying imagine you growing up
all your life boxing and you like a earl
spitz and you get overshadowed because
this one his biggest
like he literally came back from a year
and a half layoff because that
crazy actually bro that actually was you
saw the car did you see it it was
brutal right and he comes back and fight
the top
three welterweights in the world no to
nothing she's
and dismantled him and it's a little bit
a little bit i probably oh bro
it was even clicker on espn it wasn't
remember it's up there it's another
organization
so it was on i forget what it was on my
i forget who put it on but but is this
so is that boxing's fault
oh yeah boxing is a nightmare because
it's basically all
different leagues yeah like the almost
they're they're called promoters like
one with bob aaron yeah the others but
hopkins el heyman al haymen
yeah al hayman uh aaron are the two big
dogs
but it's basically like bellator and ufc
they don't really cross pollinate
no that's a real problem but it's bob
aaron's fault i heard
like bob it's all their fault like you
can make the deal if you wanted it's
everybody's fault
yeah golden boy bob aaron yeah and it's
just it's not good
and so ufc just keeps it just well well
keeps it i mean keeps it 100 they they
like
you want it like this matchup of
ferguson and charles oliveira that's
fight we all want to see
they don't do these build up fights
where it's like you're going to fight
this person before you fight
deontay wall wilder if you rank five
it's again
if you if you're in the top 15 you're
not fighting the 27th guy
you're only fighting ahead of you 15
that's awesome thirteen's fighting
ten ten's fighting five five's fighting
two more
and three's fighting two and then
whoever wins that's gonna fight one
like there's a reason to their match why
don't they do that in boxing because
boxing has way too many belts
now way too many now it's hard to keep
they don't need that many huh
it's just it's for the public it's just
confusing
oh you know ryan garcia is a silver
champion you know what that is
no exactly so uh
just like like get rid of all these
paper like
in the same way class tank davis is the
champion yeah
dan van heenly is a devin hayley is a
champion and
ryan garcia is a champion why doesn't
ryan fight tank davis well we'll be
they're trying can we get that can i can
i request that you're a bad fight for
ryan right yeah but he's just not ready
yet but that's the other thing is like
but here he's promoters young dude he
has a way to go so in the ufc it's like
ryan would probably be ranked in that
he'd be like 15th or 14th okay
they're not going to match him up with
the number one guy in the world they're
not going to do that to him really
and no they'd give him 14 and then you
give them 10 then you give him five
i love that but here's when we then we
go on the right we're going so he'll
never fight tank well yeah
but if you listen ufc i love that's a
great analogy right
the guy let's say ryan davis is 15 in
usc tank davis is number one
number 15 has the belt as well do you
understand what i'm saying
so he feel like he's a champion so he's
oh so he's not really
he's not really a champion so then you
go you go to the table table like yo i
want 60 40. you're like bro you knocked
the chain he's not i seen him knock some
[ __ ] out
not tank davis not lg but do you do can
we run right uh yeah pull up when ryan
knocked out um no no no no
you're not fighting anybody you're not
hearing me he's not fighting anybody no
no you're not hearing me
tank davis is he just knocked out
granted
i guess uh santa cruz he moved up but
that santa cruz is like still tops
cruising amazing amazing knock him out
put him to sleep yeah
ryan davis if he gets into he don't want
to see garcia
i get it i love heart i'm sorry ryan
garcia yeah i love his heart i love it
he's a future but it's just like it's so
those dudes he's knocking out aren't
really good
tomato keys they're but that's boxing
like in by like in boxing
that's the difference between boxing ufc
and mixed martial arts is like
in boxing guys go fifth like four it's
50 you know yeah and i tell you why you
feel the way you feel about tyson
because you didn't feel like he didn't
find any find anybody yep
but he was scared he did fight some
people but every time he matched up he
he lost he lost like lily's lewis you
know amanda holyfield and he's trying to
invent holyfield so he wants to get
something again
damn he's not over the everything vandy
holyfield was uh sparring with the
uh big [ __ ] uh the one that
knocked out joshua
he's talking about oh
there's a video of them sparring yeah
type it in i ain't joking i think
wilder's fighting i'm watching
ruiz next think so i don't need to get
back on track
wilder is in a dif he's in like a weird
space oh he feels
sparse with uh ruiz
andy yeah andy i guess andy are you yeah
this is over a year ago though right it
said nine months ago
look at that holy [ __ ] yep no this is a
good this is 2011
2011. oh but still hey
sorry i thought it was recent my my
fault but it's still amazing though
that's nine years ago though
i'm sorry my bad that's nine holy fake
years ago yeah
yeah but is it how old is he uh 79
i love my youtube i'm trying to keep up
with this boxing world hey you thought
about that too when he said 79 he was
like
i don't think there's any current video
of holyfield no
no but but i bet if he got back in there
he's a man look how crazy boxing is now
we got legends coming back he's 58 years
old
58. like boxing looks great
boxing is in these clouts so bad like
you know what i mean
this is the only way boxing's making any
mainstream news
unless floyd comes back look at canelo
canelo
is a beast and he's having we don't know
who he's going to sign with he's
fighting people yes he he he actually
fights
column smith yeah how many times do you
fight triple g
uh three twice oh no they want to do
three but canelo's kind of over it
yeah triple g is older now he's i'm good
dude yeah no trying to fight these other
dudes
oh got it i want to see earl versus uh
canelo
look at him that's what was this
uh last week i guess november yeah let's
go he looks great for 58.
now he's always in shape that's one
thing about holyfield look at him he's
about to get the jump ropes in
oh dude when he fought mike tyson he'd
finished fifth in mr olympia he was
jack what is that video right now look
at the one with the dog
or the dog that's that's you're the one
you see the dog
he looks great you took a picture with
the dog this weekend brittany
yeah dude that lady was really into her
dog
yeah i remember that i was like
come on man oh
that happened
a lot of people think because tyson was
getting beat up he found a way out
which is true now tyson's camp says uh
he kept having
vander kept headbutt which is also but
that's what he does right yeah which is
true
damn look at evander holyfield's body
bro
he is huge let me ask you a question and
all y'all can
chime in um he's beating the [ __ ] up
he's been if
evander holyfield would have just like
talked cash money [ __ ] like
floyd mayweather and tyson but he was
always on mute but
he's like i'm gonna let my fighting do
the talking i know but that's why he
wasn't a bigger
and that's why the narratives that
tyson's the best ever and but it's like
damn holy fulfilled beat him twice yes
yes crazy
yes so was the rematch the earbud that
was the rematch right there the first
one that was a rematch
so he had his ear back on am i wrong
i don't understand these questions you
asked i don't i won't i wonder about the
ear
he was he had a chunk out of his hair he
had a chunk out of his hair did you know
someone selled it online
who caught it you know what dude
everybody tyson just threw it the [ __ ]
out in the crowd
ty buff evanna was pissed he was jumping
around
yeah still missing oh he can get surgery
for that though
wow dog how about because of covet my
son's been swimming a lot right he has
this
uh swim coach he's getting really good
at swimming
and because he's in the chlorine it
gives him a rash
so the school called the smart is like
hey uh tiger has a rash he won't stop
bitching it we're worried
like cool do you guys have a nurse right
it's a [ __ ] school
yeah send them to the nurse office tell
them to put on some anti-itch cream or
lotion and help them out
they're like because they're covered we
can't touch the kids you got to come do
it
so i had to take my ass up to walgreens
buy some anti-itch cream
drive up there so i drive up put on
tiger
and then i'm leaving and i'm like on my
phone i look up and then they're it's so
cute it's like
they have like the fence and there's
like this much gap
and i just see [ __ ] 15 heads
and i can see tiger because he's telling
everyone about my car and i
started gets all loud i hear him go i
roll my way he was papa drive fast
drive fast for my friend i see him
looking when i'm pulling out my
looking like
good yeah what else is exhausting is we
do elf on the shelf you guys know what
that is
that's where you like the shelf
everybody else they watch you so
the way you do it with kids is you say
you know if you're the elf on the shelf
is in the house right now for christmas
and he reports back to santa yeah if
you're bad that elf is going to let
santa know
so we have a little mailbox and tiger
like writes stuff they want puts in the
mailbox
got it but then also right like he was
mean to me yesterday
hope like at the end of the day i'm like
dude you know the elf's watching he's
like oh you're right
so on like sorry i was mean to my dad
and then tossing the thing
so he went but you gotta move the elves
around so you gotta make it seem like
when he goes to bed
it helps move around every day right
every every night it's a beast
so he goes to bed i'm like trying to
figure out and i always set up cool [ __ ]
so i have him hanging off the tv
so i have one hanging off the tv i put a
rope down the other one's hanging upside
down and then you leave a note for him
oh yeah that's how yeah look at you
getting all creative
but now it's like this up oh dude i
might have ideas
he woke up and they're just both on the
[ __ ] table just sitting there with
their arms crossed like this
with a letter that said be nice to your
dad
are you big on christmas oh yeah big
time big time you big time uh
well your birthday's around christmas
yeah i i hate i hate christmas yeah your
birthday's the 23rd
23rd i know bro like i i couldn't stand
it i get cheated out of gifts
you know everyone all the friends it was
like i was like i wanted to brag i was
the kid that always went to brag
yeah so i was like bro i got a ps4 that
was like cool i got one too i'm like you
[ __ ] like
it was never so you never yeah you never
get to have yourself it's not you i
never had the flag
my birthdays it was so tough for your
birthday was
on the what 22nd
it's your birthday
when the kids were beating me they
wouldn't let me they wouldn't let me
have my shine oh my god
anyway yeah chappelle so
but your birthday is the 23rd of january
yeah but
we're a month apart yeah it's december
23rd you're just jamming
i care about you we're supposed to be on
the road and san marcos on the 23rd
now they won't do it on the 30th wait
what they just call me they said one
dude on the 30th oh really yeah
so we're switching to the third year yep
oh what was supposed to be so your girl
gonna be
now your girl's probably excited because
you're not on the road i didn't tell her
you didn't tell her she don't know she
knows now she knows love is tired
no yeah yeah so back to your sets
you're good you're good on i got it all
out bring up
because parents don't know what the [ __ ]
i'm talking about that elf on the shelf
is a
yeah you're real creative bring up uh
my dog
they post these parents got creative
because this kid tiger thought the same
thing
he was dad i'm gonna set up set up the
camera so we can see the elves in action
like what the [ __ ]
oh right there this parent set it up no
that's not it
oh scroll down
i thought it was a couple of elves
because the kids set up a camera to
catch these elves
and these [ __ ] parents are so smart
there it is our so there it is it says
our son thought he could catch his elf
doing some antics on the security camera
watch this
watch what the parents do you can play
the music channel
wait what the hell's going on what is
that yeah it's a camera watch
oh that's so funny that's not really
freaky though yo that's how rich you
have to be to have like a
like damn damn how rich or just creative
maybe you're
crazy you're right what happened i got
arrested oh he's fired
oh damn yeah but that elf on the shelf
is a b so what's your next idea for the
l
ah i'm putting the hot tub
oh damn check it out we're chilling guys
my adopted folks were about it were they
yeah white people love christmas yeah
they do all that yeah white christmas we
need a lie
to do everything yeah we got decorations
of all of our
yep letters of our names yep we got that
too yeah
my parents tried to get creative we just
had like lights but it was on a bathroom
sink window that's cool though that's
cool though
yeah the what we had to say power so we
have it on all night yeah yeah
did you have one of those uh empower
cards where it's one of the
the core yes it was like oh oh oh and
then my mom's alright go to bed
you should see my the where my son has
to put the notes
dude it i'll take a picture it's so full
with just because he
you know he [ __ ] up all the time so
right
it's so packed like you're just bursting
with all these letters
yeah misspelled and it's like sorry is
mean to my mom today
what yeah it was like hey i'm sorry i
hurt my brother
dude and then if you see something you
want so it'll be like dad do you think i
can get this
i'm like write a letter santa that [ __ ]
is
i'll take a picture of it yeah are you
serious does he he wants a lot of stuff
well like if he sees anything i'll be
like you gotta ask santa man yeah
that's like i'm not getting it you get
him everything no no
we get like one sorry does santa get him
everything he wants also the santa's a
little weird because he
he's also smart enough for his figure
out he's like so hold on dude let me get
this straight
santa goes to every house and goes down
the chimney like
and then he'll go every house like yup
he goes around the world like
it's hard to keep up the line yeah yep
every house he's like and the reindeers
flies like
those reindeer we saw montana weren't
flying like these are special reindeer
he's like how they fly like the red nose
you're asking a lot of questions little
dudes yeah just [ __ ] buying to the
[ __ ] gimmick all right
did you buy it did you buy into it when
you were a kid
yeah i did and then my mom said
something but even with joanne like my
girl's all about it she's like no we got
to keep it going for him like
i don't know at some point i swim like
hey dude your dad's [ __ ] santa
yeah and your dad works his ass off to
buy this [ __ ] yeah it ain't this [ __ ]
make-believe
yeah [ __ ] fat white guy
like it gets a little on my nerves yeah
but i can't believe santa got this like
yeah pretty cool
i feel like i'm the [ __ ] scrooge on
christmas really yeah
it's different we have kids i didn't
like it either if i had kids i didn't
give a flying [ __ ] i stopped asking for
gifts a long time yeah
gifts are awkward i don't know i don't
like it either
when we have kids completely different
oh yeah yeah it's great it's [ __ ] the
best well let me just go and get a kid
then dude
i have a kid no not yet not yet just
baby baby
dad though we just had our we just had
our first talk about like living
together
yeah yeah we just it was good we just
moved in a new crib yeah
i'm surprised she doesn't live there too
no we're going to give it time but yeah
i know this is kind of chapelle's girl
said he don't talk this girl is a dime
piece
yeah yeah for thanksgiving right mm-hmm
we're going we go on walks in the
morning
and uh what did you let me see what he
posted he said
but uh beautiful yeah there's a fine
line like because when i got
into the game quote-unquote game like
rogan don't post his family brian never
post family chris on post family so i'm
like oh that's what you do
but then you see like kevin hart the
rock was famous like
like that's why i do mainly as [ __ ] with
my family guy i want to post about him
my girlfriend
yeah so love is tight she's great she's
the worst girlfriend ever
mm-hmm man yeah talking about living
together now
mm-hmm first girlfriend did you get a
place with your girls
you're not young that's not you know
what i'm saying it's not like
you're not like you're not funny you say
i'm old as [ __ ]
and i let you guys cut him off about his
sets it's not like you're 21.
you know what i'm saying it's like let's
get going bubba you know what i'm saying
listen
a little bit i don't know what's going
on in life to do that i don't understand
i don't know
britney is my brother you know listen
you know i feel fine in it and she feels
fine in it
as well like we feel we feel you've been
together how long take your time
do it two years two years and some
change yeah that's a good amount of time
yeah it's it's fine
after two years you kind of know like if
we just keep writing it out
yeah and the thing that that i love
about us we're just so good about
just we let everything out to each other
everything we really just yeah we
communicate so much
that's cool i think that's why like it
goes so smooth yeah but bruh if i
i mean i don't you're just getting
started too like you're just starting to
do the
like headline your own show yeah you
know just starting to do things and got
a solid flow
i i yeah i think i just have a very
solid
head on my shoulders as to why i i'm
able to be in a relationship
yeah because prior i'm like you read a
lot of self-help books yeah i just
always take care of myself which helps
me deliver my best to
everyone else you know well if you're
not right with yourself sure i can't be
in a relationship
exactly let's take a little break from
the shenanigans with the boys
with a z yo the boys draftkings
sportsbook america's top rated
sportsbook app is wishing you the
happiest
of holidays draftking has new promotions
and odds boost
every day this week to celebrate the
holidays
and sports are popping you got nfl
teams are racing to get to the playoffs
you got college football you got college
basketball you got ufc this weekend man
ufc 256 holla draftking sportsbook is
giving all new players a chance to earn
a sign up bonus up to 1 000 when signed
up using the promo code fighter
draftking sportsbook has endless ways
for you to bet from live betting to
betting
on your favorite players they do it all
to celebrate this weekend's
ufc 256 draftkings has given all
mma fans who sign up now the chance to
triple their winnings when placing
any bet on ufc 256. draftkings is safe
reliable secure
making it easy for you deposit withdraw
your money at your convenience download
the top rated sportsbook app
right now draftkings use the promo code
fighter when you sign up and get
up to one thousand dollars that's code
fighter to get deposit bonus
up to one thousand dollars for limited
time only only at draftking
sportsbook must be 21 or older new
jersey indiana pennsylvania only
bonus comprised of first deposit bonus
deposit bonus requires 25
playthrough restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 100 gambler or
indiana 1 809 with it again
that's draftking sportsbook app promo
code fighter
listen you're sitting around right now
you're listening this podcast you're
like dude i need to get my christmas
shopping
popping what am i gonna do well i got
you covered homeboy and home girls what
you're gonna do
is you're gonna give your friends or
family the best steak
you can find i'm talking about omaha
steaks perfectly aged
100 american grain finished steaks for
the ultimate tenderness and juiciness
and flavor it's the perfect holiday gift
my mouth swatted and reading this read
it's the perfect holiday gift it's a
gift that they will share remember and
love
and they will be think of you every time
they put that meat on their grill
omaha steakhouse experience delivers
everything you need
for a classic steakhouse dinner right
from your crib
we got great sides the best meat good
desserts
and more every order is flash frozen
vacuum sealed
safely delivered to the crib and dry ice
stays ready to cook in the freezer for
months
with omaha steaks you can avoid crowded
grocery stores restaurants
it's easy meals and more all backed by
100
money back guarantee deliver the perfect
gift
give people meat on their grill all
right or send yourself something special
who don't like meat man
with omaha steak shipped directly to
your doorstep that's the world's
greatest steaks plus premium meats
easy meals everything you need for a
great gift or stock up
yourself get uh get a jump on gift
shopping with omaha steaks today
all backed by 100 money back guarantee
all you gotta do is visit
omahastakes.com type
fighter in the search bar to shop
gourmet grill packs today
this is a great opportunity to get ahead
of the holiday shopping and
it's great get you some omaha steaks.com
type in fighter in the search bar get
your meat on listen
have you lived with a girl before yeah
yeah ex my ex that was a big show but it
was
don't stop i'm just kidding but i don't
know how to like compromise i know how
to deal with women because i have three
sisters
so i was like always i know how to win
so yes
yeah i got my reps in but i'll just say
with my ex
it's very it was very like more soothing
if that makes sense then deadline with
the woman who works
all the time so it's like so
she'll she'll be working and i'm like yo
bae i came over for you let's
you know she has work to do yeah but i
understand you like that was
that six figure paycheck oh i love the
price
but as far as living together let's just
see i do that every day and then they
kind of like you know we do the park as
we go
on the road i'm like hey come on let's
spend time we do try to spend time
together but
it's not like what i'm used to like i'm
very affectionate yeah it sounds like
you're hugging
your love language you know what it
sounds like it's not going to work out
man
don't just be real we could come how
long we're going to pretend
yeah sounds like you're wasting your
time hold on you can't waste time
junior girls live together no we don't
live together
but she's over all the time on the
weekends she has to help take care of
the sisters kids but we did talk about
moving in
this upcoming year oh well so we'll see
what happens we
bro is this like the love like is this a
little pocket
okay hmm
uh moved in with my sister and like i'm
just in like a new relationship so i
need to take that [ __ ]
yeah yeah i take my time because
i lived with an ex before and that was
fine for a while but then
there's an issue with me if there is
like
one bathroom i don't know what it is
even living with my sister i feel like
i'm living on top of another person if i
share a bathroom
[ __ ] like two separate bathrooms and i'm
good it doesn't necessarily could just
yeah yeah you just get a place with your
own bathroom yeah exactly
yeah but i think with like newer
relationships i like taking my time
women never [ __ ] like all the women
god bless you dude god bless your dog
how about on uh
fantasy island when that black girl
farted
oh she she no she said before she said
is someone tooting and her friend goes
do you just fart and she goes ha ha
too did you too and she was like oh my
gosh and then yeah she lift the cover up
oh you got to say two was it season six
or
i don't know season five nah nah we we
watched we saw it
talking about girls on youtube what
video is that chin scroll up there's a
bunch of different ones
there's a top one she doesn't fart but
then she did
is that the same girl though no but it's
a different one but what size head they
got this just looks small i'm kind of
curious those are twins
it might be a full
hilarious moments molly may
i farted in front of my girl's uh wife
on it you girls girl's wife
yeah i mean my my buddy's uh my wife
joe joe kleinstein's wife wait you
fought it
were you in no on on accident we were
like all watching this show and i was
like damn this shit's tight and you're
even gonna
like
no i did i pretended i was in there
hey what's the worst place you see you
can't do that you have to like power
through and pretend like it didn't even
happen then people start psyching
themselves out like maybe it's the couch
maybe it's this
oh you got to present like do they show
us real friendship tommy and molly may
have
oh god pineapple pineapple pineapple
yeah that is tough
i love how you called it up it's just
fought oh that's season five dude
adorable i thought too many times in my
life to not notice that hey chappelle
what's the most embarrassing uh fart you
had most embarrassing [ __ ] i'm
not
one of those dudes that just [ __ ] you
know how you know how to flip it up yes
i was like damn oh
slip up i was doing sit-ups i'm trying
to think i don't know that's it's
[ __ ]
it's a lot lived a lot of years to try
to think of that embarrassing moment
well now if my stomach's like really
[ __ ] up you know
i've seen my girl been together forever
yeah whatever but i'll go to the
bathroom i light that [ __ ] up
oh it sounds like trump it's absolutely
get that poopery oh we got that
but then i walk out and now she'll just
go you got crunchy butt i'm like
crunchy but brother cooper
don't work yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but listen get the smell out but what
about the smears around the toilet what
do they that's your own
yeah yeah what's happening with your
bowels yeah right okay
yeah are you ready for current events
and i thought we all had a little smear
no you you know how you flush the
streaks
yeah the streaks on the toilet again
yeah yeah then you put in you put in
yeah you put in paper and then have it
like do the job yeah
oh you put in toilet paper yeah yeah
flush it again that's like a parachute
yeah yeah it'll get it all like [ __ ]
condom just like right i swear to god i
didn't know that oh yeah
yeah i just i just flushing it i do that
little thing that you said brendan just
put you on some [ __ ] game
yeah yeah that was cool yeah thank you
for that [ __ ] yeah
thank you oh i even know what i was
doing yeah thank you
the worst of your [ __ ] in a hotel room
and there's only one like there's one
shower it's a see-through shower and
bathroom
dude dude i leave the this is the trick
i leave the water
i leave the water in the hot as can be
so it steams up
all the mirrors and i put on the radio
real loud oh so she never knows she's
like is he showering and jamming out
nope i'm [ __ ] no she knows
you think she knows everybody does that
girls do that we run the water and
pretend
like try to squeeze it out as quick as
possible pretend like nothing happens
yeah that's what my girl do as well
but she's that's why you wait until
you're on the precipice of i need to
[ __ ] myself
because if you're alone on the way back
from salt lake to
l.a yesterday but you were sitting next
to that dime piece i was like oh yeah
they're definitely gonna say something
i'm just gonna hold it tell you oh you
held it yeah
no yeah well you but if there's a dye
piece on my flight like if i'm on first
class and there's a diamond piece in
front of me i'm like
if i take too long she's gonna know then
sometimes like [ __ ] it it just takes a
while so then i'll come out and pretend
it doesn't make sense
oh yeah logistically it doesn't make
sense like
you want to do what that's crazy and
then i look at her like
wait are you still embarrassed even
though you wear a mask like you're never
gonna know who you are i don't know
you never know with his phone
that's not the air drop it to me right
now
all right i gotta put my phone back on
airplane mode all right i was shocked
when you did that when we were coming
from nashville
bro we couldn't we couldn't do it we
couldn't take it all that was like i
can't believe you did it you have to
well he was in there for a minute
definitely well back from nashville is
like uh it feels a lot longer than going
there
it's four and a half hours but but also
i looked at the plan i was like man [ __ ]
everybody
it was just so funny because we
literally just took off
and he was like dog you got to move
they didn't even announce that we're at
home
i look to a judgment don't give a [ __ ]
not hot
old [ __ ] it let's try it you said the
seatbelt sign was still on he was like i
don't know yeah
you know like usually they'll tell you
like and now we're at 30 000 feet
yeah we didn't even get there yet he was
in the bathroom already right he was
ready
he was ready about reading material yeah
[ __ ] i had my shoes off bro
oh you was like my feet get swollen in
the air you know
his leg fell asleep really comfortable
dude
shoes off i know that [ __ ] is good okay
another five your feet's
my feet swell on the plate oh you gonna
call me fat [ __ ] you yeah that always
happens on the plane
you had old girl feet that's not a
that's not an overweight problem
uh it might be a sodium problem because
we eat like [ __ ] on the road
yeah how long we would pretend that did
journal was it fantastic oh
how long was that time you guys had a
rising crust a journal
digiorno stepped up their game they have
like stuff across now they have like
they updated everything it's pretty
funny colorado at this [ __ ]
restaurant called papa murphy's what's
that oh yeah probably
basically journal but you go and pick it
up and then you gotta cook it yourself
what yeah they just sell frozen pizzas
see the frozen pizza game i think the
the best
is probably journal for sure pound for
pound
but the definitely right is it red baron
oh red baron's fire
yeah i think they're out of business oh
yeah
is it is it called red van buren that's
right yes but that's [ __ ]
i grew up the pilot right you're coming
that black box
yeah yeah black box come on bro that one
yeah there we go baby i don't i don't
know if that's better than digerno
though you crazy
it's killer i don't think that's better
than a journal but i think it's i think
it's
it's a solid
i get the combination it would be
sausage and
they served this at school bruh oh yeah
oh it's the top one
but no they get the the middle one the
combination
now is that real sausage no no but not
i don't know what it might have been
tofu it was fantastic i got burger king
nuggets right
my dad would make those all the time now
did you
so would you would you send them to the
microwave or would you put them in
only oven oh
i would microwave it for a 30 seconds
then put it in the oven to crisp up so
it cooks faster
christmas okay i have leftovers
even gonna happen
leftover pizza i still put in the oven i
refuse to put in the microwave because
then it gets all like
i guess you know what microwaves are
[ __ ] whack yeah yeah
how long are we going to pretend it's
better than the oven like no it's not
it's not
bro is your food is soggy yes it's
faster but i like mine just marinating
cooking
oh yeah eat oh my gosh i've seen people
reheat pizza on
a frying pan too so the bottom is crispy
white mike did that yesterday
mike white mike uh he did in the frying
pan he did it in the frying pan
yesterday he had bought some pizza
hell yeah that he had uh the night
before or whatever and he's like you
want something
you know he he did you know yeah
wherever he ordered from we did
oh that was good yes jay jay's a real
penny
yeah you better if you don't order too
large i swear to god
right what'd you tell them to stop
acting like no i forget
what else you got chen he didn't even
give us anything
did you know do you still want princess
pizza because we were
gonna do a bonus episode last week but
it didn't work out
did you still want princess pizza on
wednesday
let's do it wednesday wednesday party
wednesday because you you neither one
you've ever been to new york
princess pizza is the best pizza was it
out here too
they just opened out here we gotta get
it [ __ ] up popeye's chicken sandwich i
would fight over that pizza
wait wait wait hold on hold on now let
me ask you this we had great pizza is
this the best pizza you're saying
if it's the same prince pizza that's
from new york if they do it exactly the
same yeah it's the best pizza ever
because you went to chicago
you said chicago ain't [ __ ] oh no dc no
that's not probably what about
luminally ready [ __ ]
and then i like it the best pizza i'm
telling you the best pizza is this place
prince
uh in uh new york then there's joe's in
new york that's probably the best pizza
new jersey has great pizza because of
the water and the dough new jersey has
great pizza
but as far as la goes jelena take away
large slice
of their uh uh was it the pomodoro
pizzas probably
right up there with new york and listen
i'm fat i'll admit it
i know my [ __ ] people thanks for
seeing thanks for jumping in there first
step in space
yeah that's courage courage
yeah leave that in that's brave julia
take away yeah that's that's
oh this is the best pizza in l.a yeah
right so
i got i go there i get a large pizza dog
can you pull up princess
i want to see it oh it's trying to see
it it's probably on the gram
oh you're gonna get on wednesday cat get
to get two large pepperonis two large
pepperoni do you want the
other ones they have like a vodka one
red meat get
one get one cheese not a whole pizza
cheese yeah
get him a few slices of cheese slices
right there here's the other thing about
prince that's it right there it's the
flying saucer pepperonis it's quality
pepperoni yeah
this other thing i usually don't
recommend i don't like square slices of
pizzas
reminds the little caesars pretty low
budget yeah but prince does it right a
little user updated their pizza too it's
pretty good really yeah
they saved me they said i love they're
crazy
it's not the same it's not the same
crazy red goes hard
bro you crazy pizza is great they say me
so me numerous times i love you lil
caesars listen it's
those dollars for a reason they their
slogan is how i like my women that
[ __ ] does taste like cardboard i
tell you that that [ __ ] is
dude it's five dollars it's five dollars
it's five dollars dude that pizza gta
you own a [ __ ] pete whole pizza it's
64. wait what really that's a present
wait wait wait
good pizza bro one large is 64.
i'll drop no one usually gets a whole
pizza because i don't live around there
anymore i'll get a whole pizza because
my son's favorite pizza
so i get a whole pizza and i bring it
home then we have it for like a week
are you sure i limit everybody one slice
a day
i hide it i put in the other fridge one
slice bro are you seriously
rationalizing a piece my girl split a
slice yeah
yeah oh dude it's fantastic
you got my picture on the wall there
yeah that's how much you oh
okay look at yeah look at that right now
it's fantastic
y'all some thick boys for real though we
are i don't know how demographic but i'm
pretty sure there's like people that's
pulling up to the shows
with wheelchairs and we're safe space
safe space for thick people man
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait till we go
to austin in the january austin san
antonio has great food
great yeah where did we eat last time in
san antonio that was so good that we was
like yeah we got to go back
not the hotel right not the home no not
the well no we at the
at the hotel we ate at my favorite
that's my favorite hotel that's your
favorite hotel was it that and we ate
like some food and we just kept like the
hotel emma
my favorite spot in north america about
a big flower fireplace right
yeah that's my spot but where did we eat
out there i mean remember it was like
coming we remember we ate at a oh yeah
where was that you see i'm saying i
don't remember but we ate at a mexican
place there remember with the shoe guy
sure did we did do that but wait wait
time out now we ate another spot it was
like bro we got to keep this coming we
all looked at each other
what of you [ __ ] don't figure
out this spot right i'm sitting here
drooling
trying to figure it out it's pizza on
wednesday though it's going to be frozen
wednesday
pizza party on wednesday guys oh my god
pizza party pizza party pizza
and when we had to cancel the bonus
episode chappelle and our group
chad's like i was excited for pizza
we're gonna do a bonus pizza party
episode yeah
i can't announce the news yet why we
missed that but
i will okay he will yeah whatever hi jim
what do you got what can you announce
chin said three words this entire
podcast
i'm saying to know what you can't say it
on there i don't think i don't know it's
early it's too early i just yeah
okay so this is scary as [ __ ] um a woman
in maryland
was in her apartment it looks like it's
a studio apartment
you kind of look around and you see the
entire thing she's recording a tick tock
video like a dance video she's literally
just vibing in a room making a video for
tick tock
when suddenly she hears something like
right by her side next to her like
balcony door
and a man opens it up there's a man
that's been
kind of like watching her for a few days
in her neighborhood
walk back and forth and then he broke
into
her apartment while she's filming this
ticket you just came through the front
door
it does look like that's the door to her
balcony so he got onto the balcony
opened it up she caught it on camera she
runs out
is she a kid uh no she is a woman she is
a young
she looks like a little kid no she
doesn't she doesn't uh-uh
but yeah this is the video i can tell by
a body type she
that's a little kid yeah she got a kiss
buddy
it's a terrible video
who are you who are you please get off
please get out no please get out
are you sure yes who are you
please get out of my apartment right now
please get out of my apartment right why
would you talk that much i would just
bail i would just run yeah get out
holy [ __ ] and that's her balcony
she need to do laundry no i shoulda
please come in
jesus christ so she ends up calling the
police the police comes
and they arrest him i think he's
currently being held on
bond but he had a bunch of other [ __ ]
that he was arrested for
did you see did you see homeboy that
broke into uh oh
demar derozan yeah but he was there to
break it because he's
uh kylie jenner yeah he was there to
scout out kylie jenner's place
and he broke into india i arrested him
no he broke into hers or his
because he thought it was kylie jenner
he's trying to get and she's getting a
restraining order against him now what's
that but the moral was
that dude was like hey bro like you know
damaris from compton i don't know why he
didn't whip his ass
well he the guy was like yo he tried to
reason with him he's like hey man
i wasn't
he's so ugly
man let's jump yeah i swear that was a
kid that's not a grown ass
oh that's the guy that broke in the
girl's apartment yeah
and that's the thing he said are we
friends yeah he said are we friends
she said no he said are you sure jesus
christ that's her
that's her that's her why she looks so
crazy right there i know she looks
different
inside edition and then
do they have the picture of the tried
breaking into kylie jenner's house well
demarco rose tomorrow yeah demarco
the more demarco tomorrow
no not images if you type in breaking
and then go to news not images
confronted nah yeah cause the dude was
in his kid's room
yeah he was like well that's what you
but the more
that happens he should have knocked him
out no i don't have a picture yet though
yeah you really get something
he goes i grew up in california i've
been through worse
no [ __ ] upset he's lucky
uh he didn't beat the show that guy i
know
damn it's crazy how they would he broke
into the wrong house
yeah how do you know what this was here
now uh he said look he said
he was trying to get into college kylie
jenner's house but made a mistake
eventually the man was eventually
arrested and has been charged with one
count of phillip
telling me but it's like
so you put a restraining order it was
the thing it was did you just
she has a bunch of security i think it's
more of a legal thing so
i think like if he goes within a certain
amount of distance he's going to be
arrested right away because then it
becomes a felony where the [ __ ] are
security though that's him no well this
is the same name so i don't know if it's
actually him
but justin bieber i was like damar why
do you beat this [ __ ]
yeah how do you not beat the [ __ ] up no
she's about to say it don't worry kylie
can take him
clear that's the wrong guy yeah but much
love to that girl
i'm sorry that that happened to her i'd
have been what else you got jen
okay so uh this girl's name is gabby d
martino
uh she is a famous vlogger on youtube
she has a
vlog channel with her twin sister and
she's so popular
she ended up on the thank you next music
video for ariana grande
she has a only fans account and
i believe it was early last week what
she did was she posted a photo of her in
a robe and then it kind of shows her
underwear and it says can't keep my
panties on
or something like that and she puts up a
pay-per-view option on her only fans for
three dollars you can buy
whatever the hell she posted and it was
a video a very short video
when people bought it they assumed it
was gonna be her kind of like
in lingerie or like she takes it off but
they thought it was gonna be her at her
current state it was a video of her at
three years old
with the dress flashing the camera and
so
she legally made people but like
technically she made people buy some
child pornography
she ended up taking it down and she
tried to save face by saying that she's
using her only fans almost like a
offense a fake instagram account where
she wants to be closer to her fans to
show
home videos and stuff like that she
later
backtracked and said that she was
trolling didn't think she was going to
get in trouble
she backtracked again and apologized
saying that she was so detached from
reality and
didn't know that people would take her
dark sense of humor so inappropriately
she put never a million years and i
think that's something i thought was so
innocent could be looked at such an
ugly way i think that's where the
problem lies i realize
i'm so detached from reality that even
crossed my mind this could be viewed
like this
but the caption she had for it before
people paid was can't keep my panties on
and she thought i'd be like funny yeah
she's trying to be funny
she thought it was gonna be funny i
guess i really don't know but she ended
up
having to return all the money and that
only fans took down her account
what so is that a felony like it is
if a 16 year old takes a naked photo of
themselves and send it to another 16
year old
that person is then breaking the law
even if it's of them that's still child
pornography and you're still
distributing it yeah so she can gain a
lot of trouble she can get a lot on
trump okay
even if it's her are our people are
people people were so
they said right here it's such a mistake
now listen should she be canceled not be
able to work
no no like it it's just like she's so
detached and just
so stupid i think i think that i think
she's really unattached from reality
stupid yeah yeah
how does she yeah uh she's like around
my age like early twenties
yeah she's younger than me the account
in question is deactivated
mm-hmm her only fans got taken down but
is she like is she yeah she's like
she's a very popular like lifestyle
beauty vlogger she
her and her sister's vlog channel have
10 million followers on it
that's a lot of subscribers so she's
like making a lot of money
she has a huge following i think a lot
of her following
was also like kind of young girls who
were into like beauty and long-term
tick-tockers and youtubers one thing
like this can just royally [ __ ] you
royally oh dude twenty-five she's that's
what i'm saying bro
she's playing a big she learned yeah
she's i mean
yeah i love ariana grande i think she
looks like ariana grande rain on me
ring you look at that tripping that's a
banger bro
y'all she looks like your chrysler 300
and ariana grande looks like a
[ __ ] fans royce yes well i didn't say
she was the
better looking version of ariana but i
mean she said she was saying it's some
similarities so there's no similarities
there
there's no similarities y'all can see
how long i'm going to pretend y'all
gonna sit here
i don't see what oh my god ariana is way
better looking
cat is this something that's her trying
to look like am i tripping
oh you know what's crazy though there's
a girl on tick tock who got super
popular because she does look like
ariana grande when she was on
nickelodeon her character cat with the
red hair
yes there's a girl who like made an
entire grande's on nickelodeon yeah
she started on nickelodeon she started
on the show victorious yes
what yeah she was like a white girl on
there no she had this high voice she was
very
yeah she played like this like here yeah
yeah right right
yeah uh she looked much more white on
nickelodeon
but she started off on nickelodeon as a
child star and she was on broadway
during this time too so like she always
was super talented when tick tock popped
off this girl
made a video a bunch of people said she
looked like ariana grande from that show
and now her whole career is pretending
to be ariana grande
on tick-tock ariana grande ended up
coming out saying like hey can you stop
like kind of
doing this because it's making me
uncomfortable because she's not she's
doing videos that look like ariana
grande
but doing it in the style of her
character so it's like conflating the
two there's no separation she looks
that's the girl yeah this is the girl
she looks just like and ariana grande
asked her to stop she wouldn't stop
and so her whole career still to this
day is i am already
like pretending to be ariana grande
that's ariata
bro that's scary that's crazy that's a
doppelganger so it
like can you only imagine like if she
[ __ ] up how many people think it's
ariana grande [ __ ] up
and she's dressing and doing yeah like
on purpose she does
she lives her whole life purposefully
looking like ariana grande
i could not live my life off someone
else 671 just 8.4 million on tick tock
mm-hmm god she's popping onto her and
does she do like wild [ __ ] where it
makes ariana look bad like
look at that ariana look like an idiot i
will say it makes her look like
her character because she's on the show
where she's like no she can't dude it
doesn't end well for this girl
you're not just pretending to be a
famous celebrity so
that's something she doesn't like ariana
as like she's not a fan anymore because
ariana asked her to stop doing this
but she still makes money off of her
image and her likeness
you could tell by the teeth it's not
working because they look very similar
before she even did her makeup and hair
to look like ariana grande but now she
plays into that character so here's
she is profiting off what does she look
like without that makeup
you have to go like kind of far back yo
here's the thing about she's probably
so sh you know ariana has stalkers and
and why would you invite that trouble
oh my gosh she looks so different bangs
she's like a regular white girl showed
ariana for a while though yeah okay
no victorious okay she looked like
regular white girl but she has star
potential this girl
well johnny has real talent she's one of
the best singers of our generation
mm-hmm let him know
thank you next album yeah come on
decided oh what
she did what else you got chin that's
weird man right isn't that weird
someone's whole life and whole career is
based off of looking like something yes
rudy got caught farting again yes
oh my god he was speaking in uh
he was speaking about like overturning
votes in michigan and
in the middle of like him speaking he
lets out a fart
and the person next to him i think it's
like his like a sister or something
she's kind of like
trying to play it cool it's the second
video he really before him yeah yeah you
just get to an age where you don't get
you gotta go
your sphincter muscle just lets loose
after a while
the girl next to him
she had to hold it
he kept going though see brendan that's
what you should have done just kept
going
you know a certain age or you just don't
you give me [ __ ] how about her
acting like just thinking like oh larry
king did it all he like he'll just be
interviewing farting
really oh yeah you just get so old
you're like i don't give a
[ __ ] let anybody think yeah let it out
go to larry king farting jen
who else is famous that got caught
farting there's a few of them
there's a few of them it's so funny
partner
is funny though
dark is robert malley who served as
special assistant
to president clinton for arab israeli
affairs is now director of the middle
east and north africa program
for the international crisis group let's
get first the thoughts of congressman
rohrbach on what you've heard so far you
see any any
optimism here
[Laughter]
[Applause]
there has to be a clip of famous people
on here farting bruh that was a wet one
it was like some south park fort
thank you
oh wendy williams i already know she is
oh really she's a big girl come on man
she is
some things in life that everyone does
even if we'd rather not admit to it the
worst of all being anything related to
bodily functions hey what's up guys yeah
cool story mckenzie
here's one that you might not have heard
about involving golf superstar tiger
woods
during one of his golf competitions
while waiting for his golf opponent
graham macdonald i think she just might
be talking about it god yeah get off yes
this clickbait stuff gotta stop yeah i
don't know all right go on
okay you guys were talking about this a
texas high school football player was
charged with assault after tackling a
referee during the game he is currently
held on
ten thousand dollar cash bond he [ __ ]
lit this ref up
because they eject them out of the game
for like an illegal hit they came
running from the sidelines and lit this
old ref
up watch everyone's boo and look boom
[Applause]
yep boom his team was trying to get him
too 72 just fat and slow though
he was
dude he's never going to play football
again ever ever
i mean wait so why did he hit him cause
they eject him out of the game
because he was roughing up other like
their attack their quarterback or
whatever too so he has like
he has an issue with anger clearly how
about we watch that uh game
uh with byu quarterback kept getting
roughed up by coral uh carolina oh uh
old school carolina that's a great game
this kid's [ __ ] man
yeah he is he's also 18 so
he's oh in high school but he's 18. do
you think he happened like
the ref he's the right he's injured i
forgot what exactly
uh what type of injuries he has but i
believe he's concussed and that's a
serious boy
it's just it's a mess i really thought
he was flopping yes
hold up he [ __ ] ran out there
the video is long what happens after
boom
where the ref is 72 and what happens
after that chin
they just apprehend the dude yeah he
ended up being arrested
shortly after jesus christ
the ref got up right they clapping
oh no i'm sorry just replaying it over
and over
bro he that pisses me off
yeah [ __ ] punk yeah that's not cool
at all he's [ __ ] i mean he'll never
i don't know if he had any aspirations
to uh play after this but that ain't
happening
i mean that hit a couple of teams yeah
[ __ ]
what else you got me something nice
because that made me mad
yeah that's [ __ ] up this is a little
bit
older but i thought this video was
pretty interesting because
so this girl i guess fell asleep and
then drove off into a river
and this is really cold conditions and
then the police officer i'll just show
you the video here that
this police officer starts panicking and
his other officer
kind of talks him through it
chin dive deep for this one
you got your bone off top yeah it's just
it's fascinating to see how police
was a couple weeks ago yeah you said
it's cold out there as well yeah
it's like freezing cold
[Music]
i got you jimmy just be cool
i can't breathe i got i got you i got
you he's a cold ass walking
[ __ ] here relax hussy
relax yeah i will miss tell her to get
away and bust that window
open the back door she can't get all the
doors are locked
i can't my foot is stuck in a rock my
foot is stuck in a rock
hold on let go let go let go now i'm
gonna hold your hand
let go okay here
take this tomahawk turn away turn away
turn away
come on is there anyone else in there is
everyone else in the car
yep
so long story short that was good yeah
the
officer wanted to not be there like he
was ready to bounce and
his officer buddy convinced him calmed
him down and then he was able to save
that woman's life
man that was great what are you doing
what are you laughing at what did you
what are you saying wait wait wait
that's funny what's going on
so i'm gonna be
i'm more worried about the cop that's
the that's the thing i wanted to
highlight too because like the cop was
about to be like no i'm not doing it
i can't breathe let her die what
what break the window dude yeah here you
think this [ __ ]
he was freezing though yeah if you've
been in stupid like ice cold water
you can't breathe your body shuts down
it's in shock yeah
you know listen to ice cold water many
times so all the time i'll tell you what
is
it but it's a mental thing you're like
yo you're a mental thing too
when you panic you can't breathe so so
we're sad about
the cop in the water right i mean you're
not sad about him
and i'm i'm i'm more concerned about his
lack of coolness under high pressure
situation
he's freezing yeah okay the girl is
about to sign up for
okay yeah hey the ref who got hit i mean
it's good
hey that rev didn't sign over there it
wasn't now that ref did not sign up
you're right
he was 72 running up and down that's
right all right what else do we have
were you talking about have you heard
about uh did we talk about him already
we talked about his death and we were
like
what happened exactly so there's more
information yeah oh you got the info i
mean go for it
so this dude is the you know ceo of
zappos worth a gillion dollar 840
million net worth
yeah no will right but they said once he
sold
and even during the pandemic started
getting really weird started
experimenting with drugs all the time
doing xc
mushrooms yeah he got really into fire
so he bought this place in
um park city utah and they uh
he liked his house so he went in and was
like hey and i'm gonna buy this house
paid some crazy amount of money the
family said all right cool you can have
for that much
but he's like you gotta get out the
family was already living yeah he's like
i want this house had a private lake it
was
sick so he pays a crazy amount of money
the family's great cool he's like
but i want to live in it tonight you got
to get out it's like all right
so then uh he moves all [ __ ] in they
have movers in there and the mover said
he had over a thousand candles he's
obsessed with fire so what's weird is he
died in connecticut i think
but he was in a shed he went out there
and he
he liked to do stuff like he wanted to
see how long you could go without eating
how long could you go without oxygen
like sound like you got pretty weird
so he he got into candles because
i guess for him it was more like you
know down to earth
old school type of thing he did he
wanted to be like more like natural and
old school
so he got crazy into candles he also got
his nitrous oxide they think
he was doing nitrous oxide so obviously
if you mix those two that's super
flammable
so i think that's possibly how he died
here's the other thing that's suspect
though too
he goes to shed in connecticut where
he's gonna experiment with
uh uh [ __ ] carbon dioxide right
nitrous oxide and candles and [ __ ]
but when he was in there he told his
friends and family like hey he goes hey
i'm gonna mess with this stuff
check out me every five minutes and he's
been to rehab like two or three times
they never worked out
so they're planning to send rehab that
day he died but that day he died the
caller called and they went we'll just
open the door like we can't
he pinned himself in so when they're
trying to get in the door they can't
open the door so it's
it's it's suspect i don't know if it's
suicide i don't know if his family's
thinking that
but they couldn't get in because he was
barricaded so he had no will
no will which is weird it happens uh i
don't know
his brother and uh his dad take over
like all of his state
state got it and also another weird
little thing is uh jewel
the singer jewel she was i guess really
good friends with him
and then she noticed that he was doing
more drugs and stuff
as of late so she warned him to you know
you got to get your life together
like moments before this happened so
she noticed that he was taking all kinds
of different drugs so there there's
something there
they said so he moved to park city yeah
and he wanted everybody to move with
them are you okay i'm just reading be a
badass asian and then
sign up that's a
the picture and then it was like i
thought that was cool but what's weird
is
so look he dipped as low as a hundred
pounds he went on these weird diets
where he wouldn't eat
or he did this diet where for a day he
only ate foods that started with an a
then he started with a b c went through
the whole 26 days something like that
so you do like too much money that's
what i'm saying buddy just [ __ ] him
and also with the pandemic he was by
himself a lot because i guess he
surrounds himself with yes men like his
real like
dudes the smart guys we're like dude you
need to would tell them no to certain
things
but we moved to park city he moved in
the people that were yes men
and like surround himself with all these
yes men who do drugs with them
it's a real sad story yeah that's
satisfying he was only one in his 40s
46 i think he was stupid rich i mean 870
million and crazy smart
successful all that stuff yeah this is
like his third company they sold for
millions of millions of dollars a
thousand candlesticks that's right
here huh witnessed candles which say
saw the symbol of simpler time so he
wanted to just ground himself
i'm guessing plus all the psychedelics
it got you know messed with your head
it's just that's something that's some
rich [ __ ] so you're saying he it was
you don't think it's a suicide well it's
suspect
it's suspect it's very special but
because he's really depressed too
because he couldn't like
during the pandemic he wasn't like
around a lot of family and friends like
he was weird yeah
yeah but because his friends noticed he
was doing drugs and stuff like that so
that's something to take into
consideration
like it could just be him just out of he
could have made a mistake too
like he's in that shed he's [ __ ] out
of that nitrous and there's flames
a thousand candles you know how
dangerous candles are candles are
crazy dangerous especially a thousand of
them you can't put out like one
running around no trust me i'll watch it
that's some rich [ __ ] yeah
real can't even cast a spell that's like
that story from uh
what leonardo dicaprio that movie he was
in where's gatsby yeah they're a great
gasp well then he had like milk
he was like naked inside this is that
when he fights the bear that is not no
he was playing someone that was real
like a very famous pilot or something
like that
private ryan no leonardo dicaprio yeah
i'll look it up man wait what milk now
you gotta be honest
if you can no it might be some great
movie well you're thinking of clockwork
orange yeah they use milk in that
how does this have to do with this guy
and all the cameras yeah oh wait time
he was saying that his weird [ __ ] his
weird antics
i think is what do you know rich you
gotta be like man i only [ __ ] with
candles dude
and i would be like yeah i get that hey
we're in a 400 million dollar manchester
the aviator the aviator
the aviator oh jake john c riley isn't
it
it came back uh what wait what was he
doing with the nitrous
i don't know what's getting high oh you
could is that what yeah
yeah it's like a it's a gas like a
whippet god oh like whip it
what's a whip it i don't know what it's
like
dude think how rich you got to be to be
like i just [ __ ] with candles
folks with candles and nitrous like yeah
that's crazy dude but
zappos he's like you're selling shoes
online
yeah like millions of shoes on he's
living a very silver lake lifestyle
very it doesn't make sense yeah no sense
why would he move to park city utah park
city is [ __ ] dude
he has that much money too like he had a
home there he had a dope place in vegas
yeah he had like i mean it's 800 million
dollars doug
park city you can get us you should see
a script
he had his own private lake yeah it's
his lake
is his house the backyard was his own
private lake
damn sunday it's gonna be lit you get
so rich and famous and not really famous
but so rich where you just like
what do you do when you have that much
money and you can live a normal life
because nobody really knows you
that might be the best right that must
be the best thing yeah just
yeah the money without the fame that's
[ __ ] that'd be
that seems like the perfect scenario
best case scenario
but what do you do to occupy your time
[ __ ] well he was a smart dude they kept
coming up with all sorts of businesses
and then he was also a really good dude
so like he moved to vegas
and he wanted the community to do good
so he would invest hundreds of millions
of dollars
into that like downtown vegas you guys
like it it's dope now yeah a lot of
that's because of him
like he made all that [ __ ] dope park
city put a bunch of money in park city
he was a good dude really smart it's
such a [ __ ] shame man that's a big
you want brilliant minds like that like
who knows what he would have done next
yeah i want i want his documentary now i
want to
like they're they're most likely to make
one about it's going to come out soon
but that's the best case scenario if you
yeah
800 million no fame yeah you just buy
all the [ __ ] cars whatever like
whatever the [ __ ] you want no one
bothers you
yeah fly private that's the best
restaurant
but you said during quarantine he
probably went crazy
they said he like yeah like you know
because his normal group of friends
that's what i'm saying so it's just
dude how about this get super dark in
three two one how about the one kid
who's like i'm [ __ ] sick of
online schooling oh so they logged onto
you haven't heard this
dude it's gonna get so dark in three two
one twelve-year-old
logs on to online school he kept saying
i didn't want to do it so he logs on the
whole class there
12 years old oh my god
all those kids are [ __ ] now
new sims like i still think we should
keep them locked down though right
wow it's kids imagine you can't like
kids are in prison
and you just told us earlier like kids
can't pass into each other so why
are you doing this zooming and we're
still locked down let's do it
we started what else you got jenna he's
ready for that one
there's been some sad current events
there's some happier ones coming in all
right
so nba officially spends random error on
the testing for 2020
2021 time yeah
yeah j.r smith was happy he's here so
that's good
step in the right direction they don't
even they don't even get tested that
much though
now if you're failing for marijuana nba
it's like dude yeah they don't even get
tested
like it's not like a heavy thing it
sucks because people do get caught and
then
you get punished for that they just
happened in mma where they had to
turn around you can smoke weed at mma
not like the day of the fight
if it's in your body like they don't
want you behind during the fight oh got
it
what's weird to me is when the wwe
reports a guy getting busted for
steroids
the who why yeah why why would they do
that i don't know
they did that yeah like he's not really
like
roman reigns or something they're like
breaking news busted for steroids like
is that what you guys do yeah your whole
squad yeah but i think it's their way of
like shaming him like to get him out
maybe
yeah he's like you you're testing me
right are you [ __ ] me
yeah isn't that weird that's so [ __ ]
so crazy stupid he made that company so
much money too i know
well shout out to sting he's at aw aew
wrestling now sting he came back every
time oh
thanks for having me stupid well what
about our wrestling listeners we gotta
all 15 of them what else you got jen
apologize
oh this is good news adam sandler two
films i don't think he ever really does
sequels with two films what
billy madison and
happy gilmore no oh one of my favorites
big daddy no
anger management nope water boys
louisiana my friend dave showed me this
article so i guess he's going to do
sequels of both
how crazy is that i love it on netflix i
don't know if it's on netflix
it's probably going to be on netflix
dude how are they going to do
he lives out here in l.a yeah how they
can do [ __ ] billy madison again
that's going to be hard wow big shoes to
fill yeah he's rolling my faves
i feel like yeah water boy makes sense
yeah i love watercolor
you know the nfl or
you know what i'm saying like what are
they going to do with bodies
i guess he could be a coach comes back
he's a coach right now
or he can be do the nfl route because he
already did the longest yard he did yeah
you gotta go he gotta do the xfl
by the way i love the longest yard is so
good so it makes me
nervous really funny it's so hard to do
dude water boy and uh billy madison are
like yeah
yeah yeah yeah so something you
shouldn't touch no like you shouldn't
get the [ __ ] out of my face yeah oh that
yeah they made that yeah so bad
what else you guys think uh last one
it's a happy one or world war ii vet i
think he's 104 now all right
he beat covid oh he's so cool
jack-in-the-box no what is that that's
not jacob
jackson or jacks i don't know i don't
know that's just jacks
in the box called something else in
different states or what's hard
that's uh carl's jr jr there you go so
world war
ii vet beats covet you know there's some
lady out there she's like 119.
she had uh the black plague no spanish
flu
yeah and then it was like cancer and
then she beat covet twice
and she's like in her like hundreds yeah
it's great yeah
she's twice yeah she's a thug oh yeah
pretty cool
alabama this dude's good though man yeah
mm-hmm 104.
104. world war ii vet birthday really
is [ __ ] insane but that is pretty
much it
walking that 104. well it got dark there
a little bit but uh
it got better we made it kids survived
the dark journey
where we're together we got a pizza
party on wednesday
wednesday we look forward to this crew
will not be dark
when we're in west palm beach improv
i'll be the dark regard december 31
i meant our attitude
me stevie and jay
uh west palm get your tickets bring the
new year the right way get rid of
2020 with us west palm beach florida
december 31st through january 2nd get
your tickets t5k.com i'll have some news
about
sam sand or sam san marcos
texas uh end of january coming up soon
takes a while on sale
uh that's in between if you don't know
where that's at i didn't either have to
google it
it's right in the middle between austin
and san antonio mm-hmm
uh so we have some news on that thick
boy gear get it while it's hot
we're almost out of tie-dye and the
thick boy trucker hats
uh short sleeve hoodies we got it all
the girls too dickboy.com for all your
thick needs that oh yeah i got a
i got a new hoodie uh i love his tight
hoodie it's uh
on the go yeah chappelleacy.com where's
it at
just click on there oh yeah click on the
show yeah the new love is tight hoodie
right there there it goes oh that's dope
yeah oh that is cool
yeah let me see the back go to the back
oh it's cool yeah don't worry brent i
got you one it's actually on the way
i swear you have it ready for miami
yeah.com
for all my merch thank you so much all
right all right we're out kids